[Musique]
Je pense que ça va surprendre les gens que
vous vous asseyiez là et que vous alliez comment
ils ont fait
ça va être différent de n'importe quel
film de super-héros jamais fait
il n'y a personne de mieux au monde pour
diriger l'escouade suicide
que james gunn j'étais  excité par l'
opportunité de pouvoir faire l'
escouade suicide de la manière dont cela pourrait être fait de
mon point de vue,
celui-ci est complètement unique c'est un
film de guerre des années 1970
combiné avec l'éclat des
personnages et de la comédie de james gunn
vous avez besoin de votre réalisateur pour  mettre l'ambiance
l'escouade suicide n'est qu'un
fantasme tordu de personnages au sein de chacun de nos
personnages il y a une certaine beauté
dans la plupart d'entre eux certains d'entre eux sont
juste assez merdiques de bout en bout
être comme un
douchey capitaine américain le gars qui
croit en la paix
à tout  coûte peu importe le nombre de personnes qu'il
doit
tuer en cours de route d'accord je l'ai compris
ne vous installez jamais comme si vous pensiez que
vous savez où cela va parce que
vous ne le savez pas dès que vous avez du sens
voir ce qui va se passer ensuite
james arrive
tout le monde explose organes génitaux têtes
bras jambes c'est comme un grand
roman graphique massif qui prend
vie c'est de loin le plus grand film que j'ai
jamais fait
je ne pense pas que vous sachiez à quoi vous
attendre
ne vous attachez pas trop, cela a vraiment été
le plus grand
voyage le plus excitant de ma vie en réalisant ce film
qui était génial pour
vous